il était une fois dans un château du
loir et cher à côté de vandomme une
princesse aux doigts de fée
marie-hélène poisson dessine de folles
arabesques qu'elle découpe 6l grave elle
marie les matériaux les plus précieux au
bois les plus rares sous le regard de
créatures fantastiques
ces gestes en traversé les siècles
depuis louis xiv
marie ève poisson est le seul artisan
d'art à se consacrer uniquement à la
marqueterie boulle
[Musique]
ça c'est la petite nique de la
marqueterie boulle qui existe depuis
très très longtemps en fait
elle existe depuis la fin du xviie c'est
andré charles boulle qui l'a amené à ce
degré de perfectionnement mais il en
n'est pas l'inventeur c'est exister
avant en allemagne principalement et
donc andré charles boulle qui est un
ébéniste du fin du xviie a amené cette
technique à ce degré perfectionnement
marie hélène a grandi dans l'atelier
parentale entre 6 et rabaud on découpe
pas le letton comme ça on dit couple les
tons avec une machine mais mon grand
père comme j'ai dit que mon père comme
j'ai commencé à découper très très jeune
il voulait pas que je me serve des
machines parce qu'il voulait que je
regarde tous mes doigts du coup j'ai
j'ai pris l'habitude des découpes aimons
les tons comme ça après l'école en fait
[Musique]
j'étais dans l'atelier donc il fallait
bien que je m'occupe donc je commençais
à bricoler à découper des petites choses
et petite marque écrit je me fabriquer
des brouettes en bois jeux l'est
toujours d'ailleurs et ma fille a fait
exactement la même chose que moi pareil
entre transmission d'un savoir-faire et
affection familiale
quatre générations on partageait ses
gestes et techniques inventé sous le roi
soleil un paseo richesse inestimable
moi j'ai un stock de bronze j'ai aussi
un stop d'archivés au niveau des
décalques dans mon meuble qui est là bas
ça c'est vraiment des trésors pour moi
et pour les générations futures
[Musique]
l'atelier mhp
pour marie-hélène poisson est accompagné
et suivi de près par la chambre des
métiers du loir-et-cher n'a pas ce
métier et on a énormément de patrimoine
bâti donc ça peut être un plus je pense
à des petits propriétaires de châteaux
etc
c'est un métier un métier d'art qui est
unique sur le territoire du loir et cher
donc bon je pense que c'est ça peut être
intéressant de par le fait qu'elle
imagine aussi la transmission de son
savoir faire auprès de sa fille
ça s'est découpé c'est en fait une
première une contrepartie en écaille de
tortue les tons et argent j'ai découpé
des travaux de restauration de meubles
bull mais aussi des créations qui chaque
année se retrouvent à paris au carrousel
du louvre le salon du patrimoine vivant
est un incontournable des amoureux de
l'excellence et du raffinement à la
française marie hélène il ya toute sa
place depuis déjà des années parce qu'on
a fait les premiers salons du patrimoine
mon père le faisait il ya à peu près 25
ans donc c'est pas d'hier et j'adore
venir ici parce que ça me permet déjà de
montrer mon travail et mon savoir faire
ça me permet aussi de voir ce que font
les autres et c'est très important
parmi les visiteurs l'ébéniste des
monuments nationaux venus demander un
conseil sur une étrange marqueterie
boulle marianne en fait il ne reste
qu'une marque et deux de renault quand
même dans la profession je pense que ça
fait plusieurs générations que ça
existait et d'avoir des conseils
techniques d'une vraie marque et euse
pour moi puisque restaurateur de
mobilier mais pour les musées nationaux
a quand même
mais l'idée c'est d'avoir un conseil
technique et comprendre comment ça a été
découpée pour voir si si c'est vraiment
un apprenti qui l'a fait aux marketeurs
un professionnel si les fastes du louvre
sont une évidence pour maman
[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres de là au lycée
professionnel de choisy le roi la fille
poisson
aurore doit encore faire ses gammes de
marquer 2 j'ai été briefé entre autres
par sa maman qui m'avait dit voilà je
veux une succession et une pérennisation
du métier et donc elle m'avait dit au
roi serait la bienvenue si tu
l'acceptent dans son atelier pour
pouvoir justement la promouvoir dans le
métier de la marqueterie que j'avais pas
vu il ya des façons différentes de faire
et donc c'est toujours intéressant à
prendre pour après savoir ce qu'on garde
ou ce qu'on ne garde pas et se faire la
preuve qu'on pille on de comment vous
finalement faire son atelier avec ses
règles ses propres façons de faire après
la marqueterie au lycée ce jour-là
aurore retrouve sa mère devant sa
deuxième école la prestigieuse école
boulle
là aussi une histoire de famille pour
moi beaucoup beaucoup de souvenirs parce
que mon
mon grand père a fait cette école il ya
très longtemps moi j'ai des souvenirs
mon père me racontait qui traversait le
faubourg saint-antoine avec une charrue
à brasser à peine imaginable aujourd'hui
quand même mon père est passé par bull
moi j'ai fait l'école boulle en
marqueterie ciselure et et gras et
gravures et maintenant aurore et aussi à
boules en déça ornementales et gravures
l'année prochaine donc
elle a fait aussi l'histoire de l'art
donc voilà c'est une suite logique une
continuité et pour moi c'est important
[Applaudissements]
la marqueterie boulle s'invite jusque
dans l'appartement de la jeune
génération
là aussi c'est la scie à chantourner qui
donne le rythme à c'est vrai que la
machine elle est quand même super
bruyant donc moi je mets mon cas je mets
la musique à fond et je ne pense même
faire face ça que je passe des
allers-retours dans son atelier et que
j'ai ça à restaurer que je continue de
faire chez moi à part mise en appart de
l'atelier donc ça prend quand même une
place assez tu viennes un petit peu
quand tu es avec moi parce que c'est
toujours intéressant d'avoir
le contact clientèle donc je t'emmène
voilà en travaillant deux jours par
semaine pour l'entreprise de sa mère
aurore découvre toutes les facettes du
métier et c'est aussi la relation client
alors avant sur ce genre de petit
coffret qu'est ce que tu penses être
capable de faire toi aujourd'hui
bah je pense être capable de nettoyer
déjà les marqueteries
[Musique]
remette
les filets qui manque la découpe aussi à
l'heure des travaux pratiques
aurore se retrouvent l'ouvrier de sa
mère un patron bienveillant mais
exigeant je suis avec ma fille chérie
chéri mais par contre quand on va
souvent ça on dit on peut on peut
s'amuser etc
mais si le morceau il est pas bien
découpé bas elle sait très bien que je
suis à refaire ça serrait revoilà ya pas
de il a fait ça par contre c'est
inévitable façon qu'on se plonge dedans
dans la faune on n'a pas le choix
le morceau est pas beau elle va le voir
toute seule elle va pas façon si elle me
dit rien c'est que c'est bon si elle
vient vraiment bise on regarde qu'est ce
que tu en penses déjà la presse que tu
en penses
ça veut dire que donc non il faut il
faut que ça roule alors or là maintenant
je vais te montrer la coloration de les
cayes
ok mélange et explique là on a une belle
feuille des cayes de type carette y est
entre affection et transmission
aurore hérite d'un savoir faire unique
pour la génération précédente la
pédagogie n'était pas tout à fait la
même et quand même plus dur c'est dire
que moi mon père j'avais une grande
taille 9 millions 3 quand j'ai voulu 17
ans faire ce métier il m'a dit bon bah
voilà il ya plus de marqueterie
turcomans sera jusqu'à ce qu'il faut
mais tu la découpe voilà donc
à l'ancienne mais bon c'était une autre
époque car mais bon ça fonctionnait
aussi
[Musique]
il n'y a pas que sa fille chérie qui
bénéficient de ces conseils
marie-hélène poisson transmet ses
connaissances en marqueterie ghoul
au delà du cercle familial à travers des
ateliers ouverts à tous
elle tient à enseigner son art sans
réserve ni secret
c'est bien de pouvoir transmettre ce que
moi j'ai souffert ça en étant jeune
des ateliers ferme et garder tout pour
soi on disait rien et c'est un peu
dommage donc non après c'est une
question de savoir faire et puis tant
mieux si elle se débrouille très bien je
peux pas restaurer tous les meubles
boules de la tête
la marqueterie boulle se décline aussi
en travaux manuels pour cléo neuf ans
une élève particulièrement assidus qui
rentrent revient à l'intérieur bien
content
quatre siècles après andré charles
boulle sa méthode séduit encore les
enfants j'aime bien créer chose comme
bad ass et créatif
j'aime bien sûr parce que c'est joli
[Musique]
c'est il ya des choses enfin il ya des
choses qui sont dures à faire mais je
prends plaisir à l'effet réel ce qui se
passait à la fin mais je pourrais aussi
plaisir à les faire parce que sais je
[Musique]
les meubles boule passe de mode
le procès des marqueteries ball lui
demeure marie hélène a su dépoussiérer
le style avec ses propres créations
contemporaines
c'était peut-être une envie de faire un
petit peu autre chose métier qu'il
n'était pas figé dans 17 et 18ème
siècles
donc à un moment donné aussi
es tu en es dans la marqueterie j'avais
peut-être envie de poser ma bouche
personnel mais moi j'aime bien avoir
toujours le dessin très traditionnelle
mais c'est les matières mas qui
m'intéresse est aujourd'hui à notre
époque on a plein de matières
différentes pas comme au xviiie siècle
et au xviie donc évidemment je moi je
suis à l'écouté de tout ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui même au niveau des tout ce
qui est résine etc
on peut on peut travailler les résines
et les découper et on peut les colorer
donc on peu attristé des chants danses
et résines royal familiale patrimoniale
la marqueterie boulle porté par
marie-hélène poisson intègre désormais
le champ des possibles pour les
générations de créateurs à venir
[Musique]